はい
私にはですね
娘が二人います
てるかな
5歳と3歳になりました
かわいいでしょ
応援だってあるん
思うのはですね自分やっぱり心配性になったなと
思うんですよねでやっぱり凶悪事件とか
の交通事故とかに子供が巻き込まれるニュースを見ると
あのやはり子どもを取り巻く環境というのがあのすごく
不安に感じるようになりました
もう10年くらい前になりますけれども私はアフガニスタンにいました
3年を務めていました
あの
楽しくやって特に危険な目にもありませんでしたけれども今思えばやっぱり親を自分の
上をねあの不安に心配させたじゃないかなというふうに
思うようになりました
やっぱり家族を持つとあの社会が
杏になったり部屋はであったりと願うことが自然なことなんじゃないかと思うんですよ
ね
で
じゃあ今
日本取り巻く治安状況というのは
悪くなってるんでしょうかねぇ
このグラフは過去100年間の日本の達人事件
トレンドを示しているものです明らかに減ってますよね
でもなんか
最近すごく事件痛ましい事件が増えているような
郵送多くメリスう経緯がしません
龍谷大学の甘い教授はやっぱりそれはマスコミの影響が大きいんじゃないかと
というようなことを指摘していますやっぱりあの
そうかもしれないですよね
あの報道されることと実際の社会の実態というのがひとくくりにできないとは思います
けれどもやっぱりマスコミによってわれわれが知るということはすごく影響が大きいん
じゃないかと
いうふうに思っています
じゃあ翻ってじゃあ世界の状況ってどうなっているでしょうか
さっき部そうですよね
今年はあの
武鍵か組織による日本人人質事件というのがありました
300覚えていると思います被害にあったの
ジャガーミスの後藤健二さんというのはアフガンにも取材をされて私は直接
シアの知り合いではなかったんですけれども共通の友人なんかがいてば
彼が被害に遭ったということですごく心を痛めました
まあそれがにも最近ベイルートトゥであるとかありでも大きな
多くの被害者が出ました
ば狂気どうか
だから町とロシアとトルコのことが今
族問題になってますよね
まあ日本人
おいても今年の夏は
安保法制をめぐる激しい議論があったのをよく覚えていると思います
安倍総理は
日本の
日本を埋めグルーアンポール安保の環境というのが厳しくなっているという風に言って
いました
本当にこれほど平和のことについて考える
としてのは衣にホンダ前なかったのかも
しれませんね
じゃあ本当に今大世界って危険な状況になっているんですかね
うん
2007年に
ハーバード大学のスティーブンピンカー教授がですね
テッドで講演を行って
今
人類は
人類史上最も平和な時代に生きていると
いう主張しました
本当ですかっていうような
視聴ですよね
でも彼は
いろいろも聖書の時代までさかのぼっていろんなデータを示しながら彼の根拠を示して
います
星関心があれば見てください
まーたて確かに彼に対する反応もいっぱい出ています
でもカナダの大学がですね
人間の安全保障レポートにを出しているんですけれどもそこでも
第二次世界対戦以降風葬による被害者というのは減少傾向にあると
いうふうに言われています
じゃあ今我々が感じているこの感覚とそのいろんな情報というのが
どういうふうに捉えれば我々はいいのかなとで平和な
が平和についてはれはどういうふうに行動していけばいいのか
考えて
みたいと思います今日はピースバイピースというキーワードで
平和について考えそして行動するということをテーマにこの
テックス大阪いうサロンというのが開かれています
そこで今日は私たりに
皆さんに
平和を考えるための3つのヒント
というのを差し上げたいと思っています
私の願いは
より多くの学生は会費等が
平和な世界について麺を受けて
そして行動を起こす
ことです今日のトークを聞いてそういう学生若者だが一人でも増えればいいなという
思っています
まず第一ん常識を疑ってください
先ほどありましたねあの治安日本のおける治安の状況であったりとか
世界の土のう
暴力にまつわるトレンド
と
報道されている内容程度に非常に何かギャップがあるような気がします
本当に報道だけ報道されていることだけをですね
鵜呑みにしていると真実迫れないんだと思うんです
最近
神奈川新聞がですね
安倍総理の安保法制をめぐる議論の中でまぁ
偏っていると
行動が偏っているというような批判を受けてそれが反論として
偏ってますが何か
と言う
海底すごく話題になっていました
私は
あのジャーナリズムのあり方として
むしろこの神奈川新聞の姿勢というのは当たり前なんだという思います
ジャーナリズムか
その時期の権力が望むようなことばかりを書いていれば
暴力権力の
暴走をどこで許してしまうかもしれません
言論の幅っていうのが狭まっていくとそれやっぱり聞けたことなんじゃないかと私は
思っています
まあどう報道するか
ということだけではなくて何を報道するか
ということもやっぱり大事だと
思います
9月2日
今年6月2日です
シリア難民の3歳の男の子が登録の海岸線で遺体で発見されたというニュース皆さんも
覚えてますかね
あの
すごく私の娘も3歳になるのですごく私は衝撃を受けましたし
世界もタブ消去受けたんだと思います
それをきっかけに eu が繁難民の受け入れを増やしたと
というような契機になったニュースでもありました
じゃあ日本で9月2日
何がトップ10足立皆さん覚えてますか
東京オリンピックのロゴの撤回の話です
こういう話
こういう報道だけに触れていると
何が本当に大切なことなのかっていうのが
わからなくなりますよね
だから皆さんは
巷に溢れている
情報というのが
本当に
正しいのか
それを疑うねと耳をでしたってもらいたいと思います
私が研究している
国連安保理んについてもらうんですけれども
よく
そのシリアの問題だったりとか久留米クリームやな問題で常任理事国の対立
アメリカとそロシアですねで
何も動いてない機能不全に陥っているという話がよくなり
されます
拒否権が問題であるという話もよく出ますよね
でも
安保理の決議ってー
9割以上が
前回市で
採択されていると言うさ知っていますか
去年63本の決議がありました
そのうち60包を前回1アメリカもロシアも
距離合意した決議です
2013年2010年
過去を遡っても同様です
これで本当に安保理って機能不全に陥ってるんですかね
こういうことからも
やはり
振れている報道が
偏っていると
一部でしかないということを頭に入れてより多くの情報に
触れるようにしてもらえればと
思います
2番目
平和を自分ごととしこびっとしてもらいたい
遠いに思っています
あの私判断できたのは5年前なんですけど
ちょっと驚いたことがあります
学生がねコミットしないんですよ
なんかやるって事やらないんです
社会人だとそれと通用しないんですよね
なんでそれでるって言ったこと最後までやれるかっていうのすごく便降ったんです
まあたぶんいろんな理由があるんだと思います
あの学生ばかりが
非難されることでもないかもしれません
でもやっぱり平和なことを考えるときは
やっぱりそれは自分のことをしっかり考えてもらいたいし
やっぱりコミットしてもらいたい中途半端な気持ちでやっぱりやってもらいたくないっ
てのは私の目ないです
ちょっと多く社員ですかねぇ
あの
自分ことをするってやっぱり難しいですよね
皆さん家庭で
平和についてー
あのご両親と版仕事ってありますか
特にお父さん
お父さん残業ばっかりで家に帰ってこなくて全然そんな社会のことについて話し合うと
いうことはやっぱり何もないんじゃないですかね
学校でもそうです皆さん中学高校で先生とか
学生との間で
社会の問題平和のことについて話し合ったことってありますかね
あんまないかもしれないですよね
私はあの
中学高校と日本にいなかったので
よくわかってないんですけど
聞くところによると
日本の高校中学高校では近現代史するほとんど払わないと
もうちょっと駆け足だかそこは学ぶという風に聞いたことがあります
国連のことについても成立したこと自体は知ってるかもしれませんけども
それがじゃどういうふうに敬意で設立されてその後にどういうことがこれまでやってき
たのか
ということについてはほとんど学ぶ機会がない
トイ
感じています
で多分そういうふうに限られたあの
学ぶ機会の中で
いるから国連が
あたかもバラ色で理想的な組織だというふうに思う人もいれば逆に
ここでは何もできないというような負のイメージを持つ極端なやっぱりイメージになっ
てしまっている
とても私は残念に思っています
で
あの黒煙のミッションというのは
国際の平和と安全を5つということですよね
やっぱりその国際の平和と安全ということについても
家でも話さない学校でも華がない
っていう状況では
なかなか自分の事しちゃったりできないんじゃないかと
という意
思います
私はあの
中学校高等したタイのバンコクに住んでいました
で
そこで
私あのまあうちの家中が父親があの駐在してたのでいたんですけども何一つ不自由の
ない生活をしたわけです
でも当時のバンコクというのも30年以上前の話ですから
すごくはやっぱり貧しい人がいたりとか子供やっぱりもの合意したいとかものを自社に
っていう状況でした
そういう何一つ不自由の無い自分とそういう子どもたちというのやっぱり比較すると
なんかねやっぱり違和感だったりとか心地悪さやっぱり感じたんですよね
それが私のあのそういう格差とか不平等っていうのがやっぱりそこは自分の出発点
になっています
なので私はあの絵を
その後に
いろんなところに行きましたけれども
あの
決してねえっ自分が政治空史であると思ってません
怠けたりも通史的なこともいっぱいあります
30歳の時に
代謝をやめて
で
国際協力の仕事をしたいという思いになりました
でそれ以降いろんな立場で関わっていますけれども
生涯をかけて
ということについて
やり遂げたいという思いは全然ぶれていません
だから皆さんにもコミットしてもらいたいと
いうふうに思っています
これらの大学大学院といいですね
あの今や自分やってますけども
こういう状況の中でいろんな世界を見て
やっぱり思いを強めていったということです
じゃあ実践者どうせいいんですかね
なんかやっぱり何か1つでもいいから
変えていくっていうことをずっとやってもらいたいと
と思います
なんでもいいですちっちゃいこともいいです
今日トークを聞いて皆さんが何か一つでも社会のことを変えれば
皆さんの人数分だけ社会が良くなるかもしれません
阪大テーマ学生2万人以上います
2万人以上が
何か一つずつでも変えていけば2万のアイディアと実行で社会が変わっていくかもしれ
ません
だからそういう風に見たさんちょっと考えてみたいと思うんですよね
これ書提案があります
これから30日間
社会課題を見つける
チャレンジを
やってみてください
難しい話じゃないです
皆さんの生活の中から色々見えてくるものをついてちょっと考えてみてください
皆さんがその生活パターンの中でですね朝起きて大学に行きます
授業に出ます部活に行きますバイトします
っていうがありますよね
その中で
あの
今までの
よりも少しだけ注意深く
周りを観察してみてください
取った高懸命できますかね
例えば大学で
授業に出ている時に
何かちょっとふさぎ込んでて
元気のないん友人であるかもしれません
もしかしたら大学に馴染めないとか
授業についていけないとか友人関係で悩んでるかもしれない
その1
何か
救う方法があるのか
助ける方法はあるのか
もしくはバイトで仮に皆さんが
地域の図書館デイ
バイトしてとしましょう
その図書館くる人ってどんな人たちですかねぇ
あれはなんで図書館に来るんですかねぇ
彼の借りる本に何かその特徴があるんでしょうか
その
図書館に来る人たちか理論のから何かその地域の特性とか
社会課題というのがあ
何か見えてきますかねえ
あの何観察対象なんでもいいなと思います
まずは
その観察したことを
簡単に記憶していってください
で記録した後に
その観察したことの背景にあるもの
っていうのは何なのかっていうのを自分なりに考えてみてください
そのコンプがあいまいであってもそれは良いと思います
よねん
でも
観察をして
で身の回りのことのことに何か問題があるかどうかっていうのを見つける
でそこに入りその背景に何なのかということを考える癖をちょっとつけてもらいたいと
ています
そして皆さんなりに
その課題について
何かできるかな
ちょっと考えてみてもらいたいと
ふうに思います
もし自分でできなければ何が起こればその状況を改善されるのか
っていうのはちょっと想像してみてください
そのアイディアを
みなさんの周りの人たち家族でも友人でもシェアしてみてください
そこから何か一つでも一つ変えられるのであればそれは素晴らしいことだと思います
まずはでも
あの急ぐ必要はないと思います
まずはそのくせをつけてください
よく観察して
でその背景をちょっとよく考えてみて
何か自分でできるかというのをちょっと考えてくださいでできれば実行主と
ということでちょっとくせしてみてくださいで30日間がちょっと足りないば1週間で
いいと思います
でそれちょっとやってみてもらいたいと思います
この3つを8このチャレンジを通じて私が申し上げた
常識を疑う
ということ
とか
自分ごとにする平和を自分ごとです
で何か1つかへ変えてみるっていうことを
のステップが踏めるんじゃないかと言うと私は思います
まああの平和といってもやっぱりまずは自分の身近なところ
を平和にしてみるということをやっぱり考えてみましょう
自分の大切な人たち
がより幸せになる方法を考えてみることから
平和の問題ってやっぱり始まってるんじゃないかと言うには私は思います
あの
やっと皆さんですよ
あのほっとくと
やっぱり崩れちゃうたと思うんですよね
やっぱ釣りやっぱりケアが必要なんじゃないかという私は思ってます
先ほど
まあ今準備は最も
平和な時代に生きているという話がありました
たとえその紛争が減ったとしても
今まだずその被害にあった人たちが0になってるわけじゃないわけですよね
まだまだ呼びこといっぱいらさんです
一人の左が被害だってそれが多すぎる
だと私は思っています
or ネス2名
たと私は思っています
まぁでもやっぱり向かうべきものがやっぱりあまりにも大きすぎると
やっても無駄なというふうにちょっと感じるかもしれません
まあ確かに難しいかもしれないですよね平和の問題一体
でも私は
今からお見せする話をですね
自分の
心に刻みながら
これからも
平和の問題ついてですね
取り組んでいきたいとってで自分では何か書いていきたいと思ってますし
皆さんもあのもし
表明していただけるなれば
行動を起こしてもらいたいと思います
1テルモの谷という話です
皆さんの piece by piece
そうですねぇ
一つ一つの行動
平和のひとかけらにしてもらいたいと
思います
どうもありがとうございました